hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advances and diagnosis of
primary aldosterone ism I'm Christina
jewel of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roads and
sponsored by GA Suen incorporated they
assort incorporated offers a broad
broadest fully automated infectious
disease and specialty Diagnostics menu
including best-in-class vitamin D these
quality assays are analyzed on the
versatile liaison Excel platform we
provide or do certain providers value
their sales service and support
solutions to hospital and reference
laboratories by consolidating their menu
in order to streamline processes and
increase the efficiency for more
information please go to WWE asourian
comm before we begin just a couple of
important announcements this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in a lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speakers we have two speakers for you
today dr. Allison Woodruff and dr.
Joseph wine SEC speaking first today
will be dr. Allison Woodward dr.
Woodward is currently associate
professor of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine at the University of Kentucky
Medical Center this is where she is also
medical director of clinical chemistry
she's a deployment of American Board in
clinical chemistry and currently serves
as a director on the ABC C exam
committee she is actively involved in
teaching and has
directed the clinical chemistry
fellowship training programs dr.
Woodruff is actively involved in several
national organizations including AACC
and ACL PS she serves on the board of
directors as the chair of the editorial
board of a scientific shorts committee
for the AACC Academy and as well as on
the Executive Council of ACL PS her
noteworthy contributions to clinical and
translational research in the areas of
sepsis endocrinology and maternal fetal
medicine have resulted in multiple
publications and awards I will now turn
it over to dr. Woodward for her
presentation dr. Woodward thank you very
much for that kind introduction
Christina I'm very excited to talk to
you today about some exciting work that
had been done at Vanderbilt with dr.
wine SEC and me by way of brief
disclosure I'd like to let you know that
dias Oren has funded this study in part
through the donation of reagents and
small grant funding today I'll begin
with a brief overview of primary
aldosterone ism I'll discuss the disease
its ideologies and some of its long-term
manifestations then I'll go to go on to
discuss the new guidelines that have
been published by The Endocrine Society
that help us in the diagnostic workup of
primary hyperaldosteronism next I'll
identify some common misconceptions and
pre-analytical factors that will prevent
accurate interpretation of the
laboratory results for the workup of
primary R zoster onanism and I'll talk
to you about how we in the laboratory
can play a role to help the clinical
team understand the results of the
laboratory tests finally at the end of
the talk we will review the latest
assays for assessing plasma renin and
aldosterone activity and dr. wine sec
will take you through some studies that
we did looking at the diagnostic
accuracy of different renin
assays to predict primary
hyperaldosteronism in order to
understand primary hyperaldosteronism
it's important for us to take a step
back and understand the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system or
our AAS the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system is
a tightly controlled system with the
rate-limiting enzyme renin being
secreted by the jet solar Comair Lerman
brain cells and the kidneys Brennan
activation is triggered by two stimuli
decreased blood pressure and sodium
renin the enzyme catalyzes the
conversion of angiotensinogen to
angiotensin one in the blood and then
ace or angiotensin converting enzyme
then converts angiotensin 1 into
angiotensin 2 in the lung angiotensin 2
is a very potent vaso activator and it
also acts directly on the adrenal glands
to up regulate synthesis of aldosterone
aldosterone binds to aldosterone
receptors in the distal tubules of the
kidneys and acts to retain sodium with
the expense of potassium excretion
sodium retention leads to increased
water retention increased blood volume
and ultimately increased blood pressure
the increased blood pressure increased
sodium concentrations then feedback on
the kidney juxtaglomerular membrane
cells to down regulate renin expression
and the RAS when the RAS is just
regulated one of the forms of
dysregulation of Ras is primary
aldosterone ism primary aldosterone ism
is characterized by autonomous secretion
of aldosterone from the adrenal glands
that's not inhibited by sodium or high
blood pressure
primary aldosterone also aldosterone is
I'm also known as Conn's syndrome
because of the dr. Khan the discoverer
of the disease is among the most common
causes of endocrine mediated
hypertension and although it's very
difficult for us to classify the total
prevalence among all hypertensive
patients
it seems as though primary
hyperaldosteronism may represent up to
15% of all hypertensive patients as I
mentioned it's characterized by
autonomous non submersible secretion of
aldosterone and this is caused by
several different ideologies among them
the most common are adrenal adenoma and
uni or bilateral adrenal hyperplasia in
far less common forms of primary
aldosterone ISM are caused by familial
genetic forms of the disease primary
aldosterone ISM should be diagnosed and
treated rapidly if left untreated it can
lead to very severe hypertension
ultimately leading to cardiovascular
damage sodium retention suppress renin
concentrations in hypokalemia
cardiovascular damage can lead to
significant cardiovascular morbidity and
mortality and for that reason it's very
important that we have a very good
screening test for primary
hyperaldosteronism among patients at
risk for the disease The Endocrine
Society practice guidelines have been
recently updated in 2016 in those
guidelines they lay out a very clear
algorithm for the diagnostic workup of
disease that begins with a recommended
screening test for all patients at high
risk for pa the screening test is a
measurement of aldosterone in the plasma
and renin in the plasma and calculation
of a ratio of aldosterone to renin
activity anybody with an abnormal
aldosterone in an activity ratio or ARR
should then be referred to a specialist
either an endocrinologist or
hypertension specialist for confirmatory
testing the confirmatory testing is
typically a provocative testing it is
typically the most common is a saline
suppression test as I mentioned to you
high sodium concentrations will lead to
down regulation of renin and RNAs which
should suppress aldosterone secretion
in a patient that is autonomously
secreting aldosterone an infusion of
saline either or large sodium loading
will lead to should lead to suppression
of aldosterone in a normal patient but
in a primary investor-owned ISM the
aldosterone is not suppressed in a
patient with a positive confirmatory
test and a patient who is a candidate
and who desires surgery first they
should undergo adrenal imaging to
determine if surgery is possible through
an adrenal CT the surgery is not desired
the patient may be treated with
pharmacological treatment clintons if
surgery is desired
after adrenal CT imaging adrenal vein
sampling can be performed in order to
determine the etiology of the disease
whether it be bilateral or unilateral
Yoona route the unilateral adrenal
adenomas can be removed surgically
through an adrenalectomy all other
patients should be treated from a
college pharmacologically with with
mineral corticoid receptor inhibitors so
as you might imagine because of the
risks of cardiovascular morbidity and
mortality the screening tests for
primary austrian ism is very important
so i mentioned that the screening tests
should only be performed on patients at
high risk for primary aldosterone ism
the entrance society actually goes on to
define who those high-risk patients
might be hypertensives aren't defined by
them as anybody whose blood pressure is
greater than 140 over 90 millimeters of
mercury in patients that have severe
hypertension greater than 150 over 100
millimeters of mercury measured on three
separate occasions on three different
days our could be worked up for primary
hyperaldosteronism others with
hypertension that are resistant to at
least three or more anti hypertensive
meds or those that have hypertension
that are actually controlled on four or
more hypertensive meds should be worked
up for primary
our own ISM in addition patients with
hypertension and hypokalemia sleep apnea
and a family or a family history of
early onset hypertension should be
worked out as well
finally hypertension and a first degree
relative with primary on ISM should lead
to the workup of a genetic source of
primary aldosterone so as I mentioned
the first step for screaming for primary
aldosterone ISM is to measure the
aldosterone terminan ratio aldosterone
can be measured is measured through a
maths a say either radio immunoassay or
chemiluminescence a we'll talk more
about that in the second half of the
talk and renin can be measured either by
mass or activity what's one of the
drawbacks of the ARR is that in patients
that have suppressed plasma renin
activity or plasma renin mass
concentrations because the aldosterone
is so high their ratio can be elevated
even in the absence of high aldosterone
secretion and for this reason numerous
experts in the field have recommended
that not only do we look for a high
aldosterone to renin ratio to diagnose
PA but we also look for high secretion
of aldosterone alone and in the figure
on the right I show you a graph that has
met that ARR on the y axis and the
plasma dosterone concentration on the x
axis and while it's very difficult to
give hard and fast cut-offs for what
indicates primary aldosterone ism with
the screening tests because of the
different analytical factors the
different types of assays and also the
numerous interfering pre-analytical
factors the most commonly cited cutoff
for the aldosterone to run in ratio is
typically 30 whereas for plasma
dosterone concentration itself
they typically cite greater than 750
Pico moles per liter or 27 nanograms per
deciliter and conventional units of
primary aldosterone ism
but numerous papers have suggested that
perhaps an aldosterone concentration
greater than fifteen nanograms per
deciliter may indicate alongside an
elevated AR may indicate primary
aldosterone ISM so as I mentioned
earlier there are numerous
pre-analytical factors that will affect
the renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
and thus affect the laboratory testing
for aldosterone renin and the
aldosterone to Brennen ratio potassium
status for example plays an important
role in regulating the RAAS and in
general hypokalemia will cause down
regulation of Aldo and a decreased
aldosterone and ratio sodium status and
the amount of sodium in the patient's
diet is very important to regulating the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system a
low sodium diet will lead to increased
Aldo and Renan and a decreased
aldosterone treinen ratio whereas a high
sodium diet leads to the opposite effect
decreased Aldo Renan an increased ARR as
many of you know when posture change
that it affects your blood pressure and
also your aldosterone and Renan Aldo and
Renan are both increased when a patient
is in an upright position compared to a
supine the ARR however is unchanged
another reason why using the aldosterone
trend ratio is a better measure for
abnormalities in the RAAS aldosterone
renin are also affected by diurnal
variation in fact their concentrations
are highest in mid-morning before 10
o'clock and it's important to consider
that when looking at the values for
aldosterone Renan I also mentioned that
there were numerous medications that
affect the renin-angiotensin-aldosterone
system namely numerous antihypertensive
medications so in this figure you can
see the Ras and various anti
hypertensive meds that block different
portions of the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
direct renin inhibitors obviously will
block the activity of renin leading to
down regulation of aldosterone
and also down regulation of the
aldosterone tamenund ratio ACE
inhibitors will block conversion of
angiotensin 1 to angiotensin 2 leading
to down regulation of aldosterone and
the ARR angiotensin 2 receptor blockers
ARBs
have the same effect they down regulate
aldosterone secretion and the ARR and
finally middle coracoid receptor
antagonists which is the primary
recommendation for treatment of patients
with PA will also down regulate
aldosterone secretion as well as renin
and decrease the ARR so as you can see
there are numerous both physiological
and pharmaceutical factors that affect
the RAAS so it's very likely that some
of the testing can be misinterpreted in
the workup for a primary aldosterone ism
and so for that reason the endocrine
society has given us recommendations for
how to measure ARR and they have given
both pre-analytical or prior to specimen
collection and also recommendations for
at the time of specimen collection so
their first recommendation is to attempt
to clip correct hypokalemia through
potassium supplements further they
recommend liberalizing sodium intake as
low sodium diets do affect the
concentrations of aldosterone and the
blood stream they also recommend if
possible discontinuation of
antihypertensive medications that
markedly affect the ARR for action up to
four weeks for at least four weeks those
include the mineral corticoid blocking
agents like spironolactone potassium
wasting diuretics and anything that
contains licorice they recommend that if
possible medically that patients also be
withdrawn from other antihypertensive
medications like beta blockers ACE
inhibitors and ARBs from for at least
two weeks prior to collection of
aldosterone and Wrentham patients can
safely be transferred to calcium channel
blockers which are thought to have the
least effect on al dose
and Renan then at the time of collection
the specimen should be collected
mid-morning the patient should be awake
for at least two hours in a sitting
position for at least five to 15 minutes
to normalize for the postural effects on
aldosterone and Ren so the endocrine
society goes on to suggest that there
are times in which it's impossible to
collect those specimens during optimal
sampling conditions and so they have
defined several conditions which
represent suboptimal sampling conditions
and we at Vanderbilt as a part of our
studies on primary Austrian ISM look to
see how renin and aldosterone were
ordered in our patients whether they
were ordered in optimal or suboptimal
sampling conditions and what we found
was that when considering the following
suboptimal conditions including patients
on greater than one interfering
medication inappropriate collection time
ie
samples collected after 10 a.m. samples
collected when the potassium status was
not assessed or potassium was abnormal
or samples collected when renal function
was not assessed where abnormal what we
found was that out of a 200 patients
samples that we reviewed 170 of those
were collected in suboptimal conditions
now some of these were related to
samples being collected while the
patient was on medications and in some
cases it's impossible to take the
patients off of these medications due to
health concerns or significant
significant side effects however the
large majority was collected either at
the wrong time or when potassium status
was unknown or abnormal and so because
of this we've decided that part of this
can be corrected with an educational
campaign but the endocrine society
office offers us guidance on what to do
about the rest of these so in their
practice guidelines they state as I've
shown here in the in the top if all
potentially problematic agents cannot
safely be withdrawn and ARR should be
performed and the results considered in
light of potential
confounding factors so how can we in the
laboratory ensure that a physician is
interpreting these results in light of
these potential confounding factors and
what we at Vanderbilt did was we
implemented a diagnostic management team
so you might be wondering what exactly
is a diagnostic management team this is
a collaborative group of laboratory and
clinical experts and the team comes
together to provide evidence-based
patient specific interpretive reports
it's not intended to regurgitate any
guidelines it's really meant to be
evidence-based opinions and
interpretations by experts in both
laboratory and the clinical arena a true
DM team needs to meet regularly the
interpretations must utilize clinical
information in the patient's chart and
they need to incorporate these
interpretations need to be visible in
the electronic medical record of the
patient and their intent is to provide
clinical value that will help with
patient care specifically our intent
with the diagnostic management team for
primary aldosterone ism was to ensure a
more efficient and effective workup for
primary aldosterone ism so we developed
this diagnostic management team for the
workup of endocrine mediated
hypertension this team met weekly and it
met the meetings correspond to the times
that we performed aldosterone and ranan
testing when we met we reviewed relevant
clinical history we considered
confounding factors like physiological
and medication factors and we also
reviewed evidence like The Endocrine
Society and other guidelines to make
evidence-based recommendations on the
Left I've shown you an example
interpretation for the primary
aldosterone diagnostic management team
and here we show sort of what makes this
patient high-risk and why this should
have been ordered she she has
uncontrollable hypertension which is
shown here
she was hypokalemic which is also an
indicator of primary hyperaldosteronism
normal renal function we considered
these results in light of the
medications that she was taking she was
taking two anti hypertensive Medicaid
jim's lisinopril a nice inhibitor and
I'm loaded Pina calcium channel blocker
both of those act to decrease the
aldosterone trend and ratio um then we
go on to say that despite that the
aldosterone trenin ratio is so high
greater than 102 and the aldosterone by
itself is greater than is 20 which is
very likely to represent primary
hyperaldosteronism so we recommended
that she move on to an endocrine consult
where they could do the diagnostic
confirmatory testing we also provide a
couple of links to how in medications
will affect Renan Aldo and the
aldosterone to renin ratio along with
the recommendations for specimen
collections which I've outlined earlier
so when we implemented the endocrine
diagnostic management team at Vanderbilt
we wanted to do a pilot study to ensure
that this was making a difference
clinically so we enrolled patients from
four primary care physicians that were
being worked up for primary
hyperaldosteronism we looked at all ARR
orders from these four physicians and we
looked at two time periods before
implementation of the dmt and after
implementation at the dmt when looking
at the patient's we looked at their
electronic medical records for clinical
and laboratory workup patient diagnosis
outcomes and anything that would suggest
to us that this was uh this improved
patient care what we found was that with
respect to both demographics and other
clinical factors there was no
significant difference before and after
implementation of the diagnostic
management team but what we did find was
that before implementation of the PA dnt
four patients had unnecessary diagnostic
testing or radiology procedures and
eight actually had potential delayed or
misdiagnosis after implementation of the
PA dmt the physicians had close
adherence to the endocrine society
practice guidelines were all patients we
did not identify any unnecessary
diagnostic workup sore procedures and of
the five patients in which we
recommended that they have
consult through either endocrine or
hypertension we all five of them were
referred and their diagnostic workup was
expedited and so in conclusion to this
part of the talk I hope that I've
conveyed to you that the diagnostic
workup for primary aldosterone ism is a
very complex and challenging the
endocrine society practice guidelines
give us some advice on how to work up
those this disorder through a screening
process and then confirmatory processes
they also recommend that is very
important to consider the numerous
suboptimal code sample collection
conditions for both aldosterone and
renin and to consider those results in
the context of those interfering factors
we used a tool called the diagnostic
management team at Vanderbilt to
consider those factors and effectively
communicate how those pre-analytical
factors may influence the diagnostic
workup and the results of aldosterone
treinen ratio our next step include
includes an educational campaign in
which we attempt to reduce other
suboptimal collection conditions like
time of day and potassium status to
expand the dmt to all primary care
physicians which has already been done
and also to optimize the analytical
result the analytical assays that we use
for both aldosterone and Renan and
you'll hear about all of the work that
we had done at with respect to assays in
the second half of this talk and with
that I'll just acknowledge the numerous
people that spent time working on these
studies including three clinical
chemistry fellows Joe wine sex sera
Bissonnette and Jessica : Franco the
leader of the DMT s
Michael a Posada and our clinical
collaborator Andrea Utz along with a
laboratory assistant Cheri Stafford and
again we received funding from dia Soren
and with that I will pass the microphone
back to Christina and aloud dr. wine SEK
to give a talk
and I will take any questions at the
very end of this presentation thank you
for your time thank you dr. Woodward I
softer wood was mentioned our next
speaker is dr. Joseph wines Beck now dr.
Weiss cup is the clinical chemistry
postdoctoral fellow at Vanderbilt
University Medical Center he completed
his undergraduate education at the Ohio
State University Halloween list he
received his PhD in the joint clinical
bio an analytical chemistry doctoral
program through Cleveland State
University and the Cleveland Clinic
secondary to his graduate research and
hematology and coagulation he completed
a comprehensive clinical chemistry
internship at the Cleveland Clinic's
pathology and Laboratory Medicine
Institute currently dr. Weinstock is a
second-year clinical chemistry fellow at
Vanderbilt University's School of
Medicine
his clinical interests revolve around
endocrinology and pediatric clinical
chemistry dr. Weinstock also serves as
an officer for several divisions within
the American Association for clinical
chemistry I'll now turn this
presentation over to dr. Lloyd SEC dr.
Wayne SEC
thank you very much for the kind
introduction and thank you dr.
Woodward's for providing an exceptional
overview of the new and timely release
of the 2016 Endocrine Society guidelines
not to mention the quality work we did
together with the very first ever
endocrine related diagnostic management
team I also want to say thank you to
everyone listening in to everyone
involved in getting this webinar
together now in my segment of the talk
I'd like to discuss the largest study
performed in the United States to
determine the diagnostic the diagnostic
accuracy of running mass when working
patients up with suspected PA
so to disclose this research was
partially supported by Dias horn
incorporated and treble support was
provided by a ACCC and travel support
was provided by a ACCC to present
portions of this talk now to begin I
would like to revisit the diagnostic
algorithm provided by The Endocrine
Society for the workup of suspected
primary aldosterone ism so as we heard
from dr. Woodworth in high-risk patients
with a positive aldosterone to Rend
ratio The Endocrine Society recommends
the following diagnostic algorithm to
workout patients with the suspected
disorder so as you can see as you can
see that the entire algorithm for the
workup on PA rests on the sensitivity of
the aldosterone to run in ratio
screening tests so now there are two
different metrics available to measure
renin to assess the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system and
to calculate del dosterone to run in
ratio namely plasma renin activity and
run and mass now each of these running
measurements have several advantages and
disadvantages to their testing and we
will briefly go over them in this
presentation so historically the use of
plasma renin activity has been heavily
favored in the calculation of
aldosterone treinen ratio the test is
usually performed by radio immunoassay
however plasma renin activity methods
for LC ms/ms are becoming more prevalent
and these types of assay renin from the
patient sample activates endogenous
angiotensinogen to produce angiotensin 1
for R for radio immunoassay methods
there are there is also a second aliquot
for the specimen set at identical
conditions but is left at 4 degrees
Celsius and this sample is generally
used as a blank for the following
calculation that you see in the right
hand portion of your screen also
incubation times for these assays can
vary from one hour all the way out to 18
hours is recommended for low renin
specimens in addition with the advent of
LC ms/ms for angiotensin one measurement
there have
many analytical advantages to plasma
renin activities such as linear
calibration curves versus the sigmoidal
curves that you would see for the radio
immunoassays there's a wider dynamic
range especially at the low end of
plasma renin activity and the LC ms/ms
methods are eliminating the need for
radiotracers and blanking incubation
there's also a high quality Calabrian
available for angiotensin 1 and that's
available from the National Institute
for biological standards and control so
there's like we talked about there are
several advantages and also
disadvantages for plasma renin activity
so additionally the use of plasma
activity is widely used because it
really has stood the test of time it's
one of the first assays that have been
out there for Radio immunoassay and the
measurement of plasma renin activity it
has a wide clinical acceptance a huge
fan base of clinicians and a
tried-and-true cutoff for clinically
established PA disorders so however
there is no doubt about it that there is
several disadvantages with current
plasma renin activities they're known to
be laborious they're definitely time
consuming as recently stated there's
incubation periods out to about 18 hours
and some of them even may rely on
radioactivity
lastly the LC ms/ms instrument can be
quite costly and as many of us know also
require an experienced technician for
running specimens and also overall
trouble troubleshooting of the method on
the other hand there are Renan Mass
amino acids which have been around for
about 20 years they were originally a
Munich immuno radiometric but are now
more automated chemiluminescent amino
acids and these are becoming more widely
available and they offer several
benefits such as walk away automation
decreased turnaround time and
importantly instrument connectivity with
the laboratory information system
however red and massimino assays are
rarely used in the diagnostic workup
our primary aldosterone ism due to
questionable correlations with plasma
renin activity cut-offs that are based
on conversion factors from method
comparisons and an overall unknown
diagnostic utility to predict PA also
there is a higher potential chance for
Pro running interference which we'll
discuss briefly in a little while so at
Vanderbilt University Medical Center we
perform several studies to determine and
diagnostic utility of Ren and mass to
predict pa before this was done though
we perform validation studies for the
direct running concentration assays such
as linearity accuracy precision and
stability following this validation
process we performed a retrospective
cohort study utilizing residual EDTA
plasma specimens from about 200 adult
hypertensive patients being worked up
for the disorder and these residual
plate plasma specimens were then
analyzed by the direct running
concentration of amino acid and then
from there and then from there we
performed chart review basically to
determine the patient's history
demographics pertinent laboratory values
medications and overall diagnosis and
then this information was then used
sorry skipped ahead here this
information was then used to assess the
diagnostic accuracy of the aldosterone
trend and ratio calculated with either
method as you may get down here with
either method by receiver operating
characteristics and then from there we
were able to determine the diagnostic
utilities of our methods utilizing the
endocrine society recommended in our
newly defined laboratory cut-offs for a
positive aldosterone to renin ratio
result in our study population
so in our study to remind everyone
washing we included patients that were
18 years of age or older with
hypertension who had a completed order
for plasma renin activity in plasma
aldosterone we we rejected specimens
from the study if the sample was from
let's say an incorrect tube type an
adrenal vein sample and so forth from
the other things that were listed on the
slide here so this is a good point to
start discussing the results so we can
move into the hassle
performance characteristics of our study
so here you see to do this let's talk
briefly about performance
characteristics of the assay so running
mass is a two-step chemiluminescent
amino acid that is running EDTA plasma
the method consists of magnetic
particles coated with anti renin and pro
ren and mouse monoclonal antibodies and
the conjugate is a mouse monoclonal
antibody conjugated to an ice ax isil
luminol derivative the overall pass a
range stated by the manufacturers 2.1 to
300 picograms per milliliter it's also
important to note the various
interference studies performed by the
manufacturer based on the clsi EPO 7a to
document and several of these
interference studies are listed here in
the screen so next let's quickly talk
about our linearity studies we assess
the linearity over the assay range from
2 point 1 to 300 Pico Pico moles per
milliliters and the results of the test
were accurate linear and precise in the
reportable range from there let's take a
quick look at the within run precision
so here we see two levels of quality
control were used on 10 subsequent
analytical runs to determine the mean
standard deviation and coefficient of
variation for each level the precision
of the run and mass assay method was
determined to meet the acceptable
criteria by our in-house criteria again
let's quickly move on to an important
topic and talk about the stability of
run and mass so what you're looking at
here is the results from a stability
study used to assess for common
laboratory storage conditions room
temperature 4 degrees negative 20
degrees and negative 80 degrees Celsius
the bar chart illustrates the mean
percent change from the baseline and the
error bars represent the overall
standard deviation we also put the
significant change limit lines in the
chart and those are shown in red and
from this study we can see that red and
mass is stable for several hours at room
temperature and for at least two months
at negative eighty degrees Celsius
so let's talk a little bit about the
concept of pro running so pro renin is
the precursor of renin and can be
activated by an irreversible proteolytic
mechanism or non pro oolitic Li by
unfolding of the pro segment and several
studies state that storage of plasma at
refrigeration and ambient temperatures
have been shown to lead to an activation
of pro Renan and therefore conspiracy
increased plasma renin activity and
direct running concentration now the
blank that's in plasma renin activity
assays typically are used to kind of
avoid that pro Renan activation and kind
of alleviate that and interference so
overall it is advised that specimens for
Brennand determination regardless of
assay be frozen immediately once once
received in the laboratory stored frozen
rapidly thawing and rapidly analyzed and
that is why it's important to perform
these stability studies when assessing a
new assay especially with this Pro run
and activation so now let's get on and
talk about our method comparisons
portions of this so we utilize the gamma
gamma Co plasma renin activity radio
immunoassay kit and the liaison sandwich
chemiluminescent immuno assay and we
performed a linear regression analysis
from 200 adult hypertensive patients now
even though these are two different
metrics to quantitate renin the overall
analysis revealed good correlation
between the two methods now it's really
important to note here that the majority
of cut-offs for direct running
concentration that's used and e
aldosterone to running ratio cut-offs
are that are available in the literature
including the new 2016 Endocrine Society
practice guidelines are based on similar
method comparisons on to the one that
you actually see here and this is why we
felt that we needed to take it a step
further and assess the diagnostic
utility of the aldosterone to run the
ratio calculated with this direct
running concentration which brings us to
the diagnostic accuracy of the
aldosterone to running ratio calculated
with directory and concentration so
through extensive electronic health
record review which I can account for
200 hypertensive patients being worked
up for PA we were
able to determine 189 of these patients
were unlikely to have the disorder the
11 remaining patients were identified to
have a likely diagnosis either by the
gold standard diagnostic algorithm that
you saw in part 1 and the first few
slides of my segment of the talk or by
physician documented diagnosis or lastly
by an elevated aldosterone trenin ratio
elevated aldosterone an adrenal nodule
being present so from there we were able
to identify these patients with a likely
diagnosis of PA which was very helpful
and allowing us to determine the
diagnostic accuracy of the aldosterone
treinen ratio calculated with either
plasma renin activity or direct renin
concentration and we did this by
receiver operating characteristic
turistic s' which was performed on
graphpad so as you can see from the
analysis both methods revealed similar
diagnostic utility to predict PA so the
area under the curve are comparable
between the two methods so in addition
from this analysis we were able to
really plot some useful information here
to be able to select specific in-house
laboratory cut-offs an optimal
sensitivity and specificity for both of
our methods that are being run currently
in-house so from there we are able to
determine the diagnostic utility of the
aldosterone threading ratio calculated
with either plasma renin activity or
direct running concentration at the
endocrine Society recommended and our
newly defined laboratory in-house to
term encode offs so in this analysis we
determine the sensitivity specificity
and positive and negative likelihood
ratios for each method and the
respective cut-offs so as you can see
the endocrine Society guidelines
suggested costs for the aldosterone to
run in a ratio for plasma renin activity
and direct run and concentration plasma
renin activity shows superior
sensitivity and specificity as well as
positive and negative likelihood ratios
here so you can see that there's higher
sensitivity when you're looking at the
cut-offs of greater than 30 and then
greater than 30 plus 50 nanograms per
deciliter for aldosterone when it's
calculating
with plasma renin activity and lower
sensitivity with the aldosterone running
ratio with the suggested cut-offs for
direct running concentration so that was
at five point seven and five point seven
plus the fifteen nanograms per deciliter
however after we determined laboratory
defined cut-offs based on our receiver
operating characteristic analysis we
were able to optimize sensitivity and
specificity for both methodologies so
you can see the diagnostic utilities
became more comparable to predict PA in
our study population so in overall this
presentation I hope you can see that I
demonstrated that the aldosterone to run
ratio calculated with direct running
concentration was really shown to be a
sensitive and specific screen test in
the workup of primary held austrian ism
especially when in-house validation
studies were utilized to maximize
sensitivity and specificity and this is
why we feel that director in a
concentration is a viable alternative to
plasma renin activity it's really offers
a technical feasibility and a high
throughput a lower cost then you would
see with tandem mass spectrometry
methods the elimination of the
radiotracers as well and this is why you
know it's most importantly to state here
that regardless of the method that's
used to measure Renan due to false
positives plasma our primary
hyperaldosteronism must always be
confirmed with provocative confirmatory
testing so with that I leave you our
final recommendations and these are
really provided by the 2016 Endocrine
Society guidelines and that is to
determine your own in-house cut-offs for
your hypertensive population regardless
of the method that you use so with this
I provide some additional references
that could be helpful in your journey in
choosing your plasma renin activity or
running mass assays for your specific
laboratory I also want to thank the
acknowledgments or to provide my
acknowledgments for the American
Association for clinical chemistry for
selecting this abstract we presented at
this year's ACC annual meeting as well
as all the healthful work that I
received from my fellow mentor dr.
Allison Woodworth and also the
laboratory technician cherry Stafford
for her help and running the direct run
and concentration and aldosterone and
plasma renin activity assays at our
institution so with that I provide an
opening for questions the abstract here
is listed if you would like to look it
up on AC C's website and if you have any
comments or questions that don't get
answer today I'd be more than happy to
take a look into anything that you might
would like to discuss and you can reach
me by this email at jo e s pH a lot of
people misspelled my name so just make
sure you get that correct so with that
thank you very much everyone I
appreciate it thank you doctor one sec
now before we get started on the
question and answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we all try to answer
as many questions as we can now our
first question and dr. Woodward this
question is for you who is on the
vanderbilt pa diagnostic management team
thank you for that question I think it's
really important when developing a
diagnostic management team that you
include a very well-rounded group of
individuals and so I'm fair about when
we when I set out to develop a
diagnostic management team for primary l
dosterone ism it was important to find a
clinical expert so we had a
endocrinologist a clinical
endocrinologist who specialized in
adrenal function and injury and renal
abnormalities and she and I sat together
and worked to develop this team we also
want to remember that this is a teaching
opportunity and we use this as a
teaching opportunity for
our trainees residents and fellows in
the pro in pathology program as well as
other clinical specialties and so what
one of the most important aspects of the
diagnostic management team at Vanderbilt
was that we had evidence-based medicine
review team that would attend our
sessions and this they're from the
library and they would attend our
sessions and they would review the
latest literature and we could ask them
any questions and they would come back
with a comprehensive review that really
facilitated our ability to make
evidence-based recommendations Thank You
dr. Woodward now doctor my sec this
question is for you what are the
specialties of the ordering physicians
in your state
thank you for asking this question
really when we looked over the 200
patients for this study we saw that the
aldosterone trend and race your orders
were primarily coming from
endocrinologist hypertensive specialists
a good portion about 10 percent were for
primary care and then some just kind of
fit in the other care categories such as
cardiology emergency neurology and so
forth so with that I hope I answered
your question
now I'm going to direct this question
for both of you but maybe dr. Woodworth
if you could answer this first how are
you planning to reduce the number of
sub-optimal specimen collections great
question
so during my talk I mentioned this a
little bit but I feel like the
collections that occur after 10 o'clock
or when the patient hasn't had potassium
supplements things like that that we
really need to identify who is ordering
those inappropriately and to sort of
launch an educational campaign now as
many of us know in the laboratory
business educational campaigns are only
as successful as the people that
actually received the education so I
think that there there are kind of a
multi-tiered way to approach the
education we could meet with the teams
if it is phlebotomist or under
laboratory control we could discuss with
the phlebotomist appropriate specimen
collections and they could alert the
physician and patient to the fact that
it's not appropriate we can talk with
the primary ordering clinicians and we
reinforce the idea of appropriate
specimen collections and also we have
electronic we have electronic
possibilities where we can put in in our
ordering system we can say please note
appropriate specimen collection times
who are etcetera etc so those were some
of my ideas but I wanted to pass it over
to Joe to see what his thoughts were as
well
yes I dr. Whitworth provided some
excellent points there I think one of
the big things that we can help to
target these suboptimal conditions
especially just the time of draw is to
really target the the people that are
ordering this most commonly and
providing an educational aspect to say
that you know this is probably the best
conditions that you can get without
potentially removing interfering
medications and stuff like that where it
would be do harmful for the patients so
that's kind of where an area that we
could incorporate also with our
diagnostic management team since it's
very active within our department in our
chemistry division would be to
potentially add that as well into our
overall standard interpretation that you
saw in part 1 of this presentation so
with that I hope I provided an
additional information for that question
thank you dr. Wayne SEC now this next
question is for you as well now what is
your opinion on the conversion factor
for DRC to PRA sure I'd love to answer
that question the conversion factor can
be useful when there's times when
there's a study that hasn't been
extensively performed like we have done
at Vanderbilt University I know that
there's another institution out there
and this is how they approached their
study and what was actually comforting
to know is that when we did our method
comparisons I met with this other
individual and talked to them and our
conversion factor was very similar
between institutions with different
hypertensive populations being studied
for their method comparisons so with
that again I hope I answered your
question
dr. Berger will direct this question for
you what happens when you don't get
discontinued medications for four weeks
good question so as I mentioned in my
talk sometimes it's impossible to take
patients off their antihypertensive
medications both for safety reasons and
because of the significant side effects
and that's one of the really interesting
things that I learned as a laboratory
person when I began meeting with the
endocrinologist who sees these patients
and she says you know while the
guidelines say that we should take these
patients off their medications it's
nearly impossible in many cases and so
that's why the Endocrine Society has
kind of backed off on requiring that
patients be taken off these medications
in order to measure Renan and Naldo and
calculate the ARR so they instead have
suggested that we interpret the results
of aldosterone and Renan in the context
of those medications meaning that we
know how those medications affect Renan
and although and we attempt to interpret
that in that context and that is why we
at Vanderbilt developed the diagnostic
management team was in order to help the
physicians understand what aldosterone
and Renan and the ARR mean in the
context of interfering medications
now if there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank dr.
Joseph Weinstock and dr. Alison woodwork
for their presentations dr. Weinstein
dr. Woodward do you have any final
comments for us I think with the direct
running concentration and it can be
definitely a viable assay I think people
at first may be put off by it but I
think that after going through and
really setting up a solid method
comparison potentially a clinical
diagnostic study could be very
appropriate for your patient population
thank you everyone
if I might just add to the previous
question about the linear conversion
between the direct reading concentration
and the primary the activity assay I
think one of the things that we need to
remember with that is that and we have
some data to show this that at certain
areas of the linear scale the
correlation isn't so good so if at all
possible
it's really good to develop your own
cut-offs as Joe has showed us and relate
those to actual clinical outcomes if at
all possible
and with that I'd say thank you for your
attention and for listening to our
stories about our exciting studies today
thank you dr. Webber and thank you to
dr. Wayne SEC I would also like to thank
our sponsor Thea Soren for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 13 2017
you'll receive an email from laberd's
alerting you when this webcast will be
available at the replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
my event thank you for joining us today
we hope to see you next time goodbye